foreign
Reynolds Cheyenne Reynolds
I've dm'd with her a couple times
let's rewind that let's go sexual and
they're all now with women and they all
say the similar thing where it's kind of
like they've had just traumatic
experiences from men but now it's kind
of like they just feel safe with women
yeah so even just with that like that's
another topic where we need to discuss
like this alarming increase of like
narcissistic behavior is causing us
women to just want to be in same-sex
relationships with my friends are
actually bisexual and they're all now
with women and they all say the similar
thing where it's kind of like they've
had just traumatic experiences for men
but now it's kind of like they just feel
safe with women yeah so even just with
that like that's another topic where we
need to discuss like this alarming
increase of behavior is causing thank
you blessing
po
okay let me just say something first of
all right this is my personal opinion on
Cheyenne Reynolds
what is that what is that noise there
listen yeah I hear it
no no I don't now I hear it you hear I
don't know I don't
thanks okay oh yeah this Cheyenne
Reynolds lady
I shouldn't go in on women like this
right but what she said there
was she's basically blaming men
she's blaming men for the reason why so
many women are entering into same-sex
relationships with other women right and
she specifically said
if we listen to what she said she
specifically said that women want to
feel safe because of the narcissistic
characteristics
of other men okay right that's why
they're entering into these safe
relationships
with other women
however pal
17 to 45 percent of lesbians report
having been the victim of at least one
act of physical violence perpetrated by
a lesbian partner according to Susanna
Rose PhD for the national violence
against women Prevention Center
University of Missouri
that's a lot 17 to 45 percent up to 45
percent of women I'm not I'm not shocked
that does not surprise me I I think that
women are more violent than men a lot of
the time I mean like because we don't
have any consequence for it you know if
you go punch another dude in the face
you're getting punched back hard you
might die right where women like no
girls really I don't want to say no okay
it's not often that I would be afraid of
a girl being able to kill me with their
hands right it's not I'm not gonna say
there's no girl could yeah and the
average guy could kill me with his hands
yeah yeah
but the thing is it's the fact that she
would sit on a um podcast and say that
women are basically turning into
lesbians because of men
um yeah I don't know why I mean if you
want to lick a vagina say you just want
to lick vagina don't blame us for it I I
have a theory on this go on I I really
think that it's not nothing to do one
it's like you're gonna say narcissistic
man but why don't we why do you like
narcissistic men
maybe it's a you problem like
narcissists are like one to two percent
of the population let's double it
triplet quadruple let's make it ten
percent that's still one out of every
ten guys that's not on every time guys
that aren't why are you picking the
narcissism because what I'm gonna do
here right okay what I'm gonna do here
is actually break this down
because a lot of women say that they
were they were with narcissistic men oh
I want to hear a lot of women say
they're with narcissistic men right a
lot of women say oh do you know what my
ex wasn't we've heard it on the show
right oh always my ex was a narcissist
I've never heard a guy say his ex was a
narcissist that's a funny thing you know
why I tell you why because what we're
gonna do have you heard of the
diagnostic statistical Manual of mental
health disorders okay go ahead the DSM
five it is the it is the the Bible of
Psychiatry and psychology
and so narcissism is actually
a mental health disorder right but in
the diagnostic statistical Manual of
mental disorders there are nine
narcissistic characteristic traits to
show that you are a narcissist okay
number one
an inflated sense of self-esteem a
grandial sense of self-importance or
superiority okay
does that sound like I'm a 10.
thank you
does that sound like the man or the
woman
okay someone who is craving admiration
you go girl you go girl
exploitative relationships I.E
manipulation
little to no empathy
okay identity is easily Disturbed
meaning they cannot handle criticism
I mean
let's talk about the show pal he caught
out the criticism on the show I mean
most women more than women the lack of
attachment and intimacy
modern women
feelings of depression or emptiness when
they are not validated
oh yeah that's that's women that's right
yeah I think that's just women in
general I sense of entitlement modern
women
can feel like others are envious of them
may be envious of others yeah
I'm trying to understand right like
women use the term narcissism all the
time so if listen everybody can go and
research what narcissism is
um and the traits of narcissism I don't
understand what I do because projection
is a thing
these women are projecting their own
narcissistic traits onto other men and
saying that the men are narcissistic
yeah I think so well that's the thing
like you are what you attract so if you
if you dated three narcissists you might
be well I'll give do one I'll give you
we're attracted to the dark Triad traits
and [ __ ] you know what I'll give y'all
one narcissist but they all were all of
them all of them every single last one
of them I'll give I'll give you one I
won't give you two because narcissists
are supposed to be like what two percent
two like ten percent of the population
that's not a big percentage but every
woman that comes on the show or speaks
on a podcast says that their man was a
narcissist well my question is well why
do you attract narcissists no but if you
read the the I'm giving I just give too
much you read the criteria but not this
though do you does that man fit all
those nine criteria
criteria
oh there's one I'll read them again
there's one guy I could think of maybe
that inflated sense of self-esteem okay
grandiose self-importance and
superiority
yeah yeah okay creeping admiration
yeah
exploitative relationships I.E
manipulation little to no empathy
yes can't handle criticism
yes lack of attachment and intimacy
I could think of
for women but I'm thinking in person no
you think of one person okay sense of
entitlement
no no I would say that would you say
that the shows that we've been doing for
the past eight months eight nine months
oh it's mostly women right you just
asked if I could think of any kind like
I could think of one but the thing is
it's mostly in my experience it's mostly
the women that are having these traits
absolutely no it's absolutely women more
than men so women would you say that
women are more narcissistic than men
I think social media proves that
like like what is more narcissistic than
so social media it's very true that's
the thing like I feel like
I feel like social media can breed
narcissism and I think women who's more
addicted to social media women well
we're talking about the full out of
feminism so okay
one of the fallouts of feminism that I
can see in the next 10 to 15 years is
that women
are going to be very lonely as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible